hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu achten folge christmas
kraft wir nähern uns immer weiter dem
gewinnspiel sag ich mal ganz ehrlich und
die kommentare werden echt immer
witziger also erstmal kurzum das ja
alles einzuläuten
wir haben immer noch gleich einen
themenvorschlag und gleichen bau
vorschlag also themenvorschlag immer
noch weihnachtsbaum quatschen von newron
mz ich habe später dann nahm er wird
prüfen und bau vorschlag von mini und
dass wir einen riesen schneemann bauen
sollen also die sind immer noch gleich
verletzte damit am berg hat man damit
angefangen
das heißt dass sie es nun teil zwei des
großen schneemann bauen
und ja also das werden wir heute ein
bisschen fortsetzung ich wollte erst mal
ganz gut sagen
zwar ist heute ja die achte folge
christmas kraft und wir alle bestimmt
schon in der beschreibung lesung konnte
beziehungsweise die die beschreibung
geschaut haben das machen wir sehr sehr
weniger wie ich das in statistiken sehr
solltet ihr mal öfters machen also habe
ich die billings teilnehmen wie facebook
twitter etc
jedenfalls richtet eure müden augen auf
die beschreibung und zwar steht dort
drin das am 10 17 und 24
ein gewinnspiel ist und dort könnt ihr
daran teilnehmen dem ihr mir witzige
weihnachtsgeschichten schreibt von euch
die müssen wirklich passiert sein
das heißt wie wir das ganze ablaufen
dass er mir einige immer noch nicht
verstanden und zwar bis zum zehnten also
in den folgen 1 bis 9
könnt ihr mir witzige geschichten von
euch in die kommentare eine schmutzige
geschichten dabei wie zum beispiel ja
ich wollte oben ein geschenk suchen auf
dem dachboden und bin dabei über eine
lichterkette gestolpert die ad astra
geschenkt hat runter gerissen
darin war wiederum ein pc und der ist
nun kaputt also solche sachen irgendwie
wir wollten das erzählt noch das kurze
und solche geschichten halt irgendwie so
in der art wo ich halt wirklich so
brandt lachen kann und die sache ist
dann einfach die dass ich mir dann davon
drei richtig gute aussuche vom ersten
bis zum 9
und diese drei geschichten werde ich
dann am zehnten vorlesen inklusive der
youtube namen dieser person und die
sache ist dann einfach die dass ich
diese namen von den personen
weiterschicken der damaligen minecraft
welcher dann diesen drei gewinnern
jeweils ein spiel zu sehr zu schicken
wir etwas dem zufall bestimmt das heißt
kann sein dass er dass der gewinner
einzelne später kommt bekommt und mit
zwei dungeon defenders will kann auch
andersrum sein und die gewinner 3
bekommt dann irgendwie ein anderes spiel
in die limburger in sowas keine ahnung
in die solche spiele sind auf jeden fall
dabei
also wenn ihr so kleine spielern dass
kleine spieler schon geiles spiel
wenn ihr solche spielchen haben möchte
dann auf jeden fall ihnen welche witzige
sachen in kommentare schreiben und dann
seid ihr schon mal automatisch mit dabei
er versteht was schnellen so und ich
würde sagen wie baue ich jetzt muss auf
jeden fall noch zwei tage darauf bauen
ich mache das einfach irgendwie so gar
nicht wie hoch ist über bauen und soll
na ja also das wollte ich auf jeden fall
ganz kurz sagen und ich habe da schon
schon fünf engere auswahl aber es kann
immer noch sein dass ich jetzt diese
folge immer noch berücksichtigen wie
sich das alles zu entwickeln wird sagt
ich habe nie dem ich das machen okay
dann muss jetzt aber ein bisschen weiter
rum laufen also das wird echt komisch
das wird kein projekt jetzt hier wo ich
mich so doll anstrengen muss muss auch
darauf achten dass ich in wien unter
zehn minuten bleiben weil sonst schaffe
ich das wirklich nicht mehr auf zu
lernen im internet so schlecht habe 16
carlos hat mittlerweile fast kein
youtuber mehr dem fast alle 32 kann ich
nicht
naja jedenfalls mal aufs thema von juwi
von johann m ziel zu kommen wer
dekorierte weihnachtsbaum an die letzte
folge anzuschließen wie schon gesagt das
machen wir alle bei der krippe die
benutzten wir jetzt nicht immer jedes
jahr und 2 sind wir ganz komische
familie seit mal ein bisschen wahnsinnig
komisch sondern wir benutzen die machen
die krippe wirklich mal so dass wir dort
auch so sachen wie hinlegen die gras
oder kies was verhaltens wirklich so in
der natur holen nicht so kunst zeigt
sondern dass meine mutter nie aus der
natur holt oder so das amt und dass wir
das dann auch dahin gehen damit das echt
schon schön aussieht und ja also werden
wir geben uns das schon höre mit ich
weiß nicht warum man wir gewinnen dafür
ja nix bekriegen dafür dass wir uns
dafür damit mühe geben aber es sieht
immer schon ganz schön aus ist muss ich
schon sagen so ich gehe einfach noch
einen höheren ihr also ich kann ja mal
einfach wenn am 24 dezember wenn ich da
wenn wir da die dings geschmückten kann
ich einfach ein foto bei facebook
hochladen adventure erschaffen werden
die 1006 bei dieser vorgang kann ich das
selber machen ja übrigens wollte ich
mich allgemein für euch dafür bedanken
dass er diese serie so was von geil an
ihm geht jeder part hat fast über hat
vierstellige likes an zahlen was für
mich echt heißt dass das ganze video
euch gefällt sage ich mal wenn ich sage
dass er jetzt nur noch öfters am ende
das hat nichts mit geld zu tun sondern
es hat einfach was damit zu tun dass
sich dadurch von euch sehe dieses
feedback bekommen ob durch das video
jetzt sehr gut gefallen hat mittelmäßig
oder her so gar nicht deswegen sage ich
wenn es euch gefallen hat gibt mit den
daumen hoch und zwar war das zum
beispiel was kann jetzt als beispiel
nehmen
bei einer täterschaft folge euch das
auch gesagt so wenn es euch gefallen da
können hochgehen war allerdings nicht
ganz so eine tolle bewertung jetzt bei
christmas kräftemäßig oder weil ihnen
das falsche natürlich schon das komisch
gemacht und da hat dann auch gesagt ja
vielleicht sollten wir nicht zu viel
streit und so das sehen wir daran auf
jeden fall ganz gut
deswegen sind die bewertungen auch sehr
sehr wichtig bei youtube und ich habe
überhaupt keinen bock das eben die
daumen runter weggeschafft werden weil
dann sieht man wirklich dieses dings gar
nicht mehr dieses ganze verhältnis sag
ich mal
aber gut dass der youtube sache wie sie
das dann regeln wollen ich würde auf
jeden fall sagen dass wir in diesem fall
eindeutig damit fertig werden
ich werde nur noch nach vorne bonn jetzt
hier oben noch ein gesicht drauf hauen
außerdem noch in die zeit so 2 bereit
wenn ich das machen denke ich denke
übrigens dass das nächste was wir bauen
werden auch zweiteilig wird aber ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob ich das wirklich
nehmen weil ich hab' ich hab mir
wirklich alle kommentare hier schreibt
es in der teilweise schon so 1000
kommentare bei einer folge den ganzen
vorschlägen so finde ich richtig geil
von euch aber ich schaue mir da wirklich
echt alles an und das coole ist da kommt
richtig coole sachen sogar um sag ich
mal
und zwar richtig coole bau vorschläge
vor allem richtig richtig viele bau
vorschläge beim bitte sendet noch mal
mehr themen über die ich wünsche ganz so
weihnachtliche themen
da kommt nämlich noch recht wenig das
heißt da muss ich schon immer ein
bisschen suchen und ich würde mich
einfach freuen wenn ihr mehr mehr themen
in die kommentare schreibt der bau
vorschläge gemacht da kommt noch
schlitten und alles mögliche nur was
glaube ich dass der nächste sein wird
ist ein weihnachtsmarkt wenn ich mich
nicht ganz das hab ich mir schon
ausgesucht und das wird auf jeden fall
zweiteilig beziehungsweise drei teil
dieser kommt halt drauf an wie oft ich
wie lange ich daran setzten sitzen werde
dort ist deutschland weihnachtsmarkt ist
natürlich schon eine menge muss man dem
markt machen dann wäre ich
wahrscheinlich eine schlittschuh alle
machen sage ich mal wo ich helfen
eisfläche machen wir damit ein bisschen
treppen und das so dass wir wieder recht
kurzer folge
und dann werde ich bald auch noch links
machen den polar express denke ich und
ja also mir fallen da schon genug sachen
ein bisschen wir werden das schon genug
sachen geschrieben über die ich sage ich
mal
die die bauen könnte das hat gefehlt
das wörtchen ich wollte mal ganz kurz
die nase dieser total krumm die menschen
lang sein kleines näschen
hier kommt dann auge hin und da kommt
und wohin wir sie ein bisschen weit
auseinander es besser dann kommt er
drüber noch schnee dann haben wir den
schneemann fertig wenn wir genau
passenden der zeit dass er mit den super
jahre geplant so der sieht sogar von
innen einigermaßen schön aus
letzter zeit jetzt hier noch obendrauf
sonne könnten allerdings baue
bommelmütze allerdings ist das problem
kümmern die bommelmütze nicht so toll
aus das heißt wir werden dort jetzt
einfach hier zu bauen
in schneeberg einen schneemann englische
bombe auf das einfach mal zu schauen was
daraus zu ziehen wir das nachher
ausschaut müssen jetzt definitiv mein
vater rhein setzt dieses handy so heldt
weiter um noch nicht ist also schon
witzig alter jetzt auch schon komische
hören geräusche konnte gleich weg gehen
aber natürlich niemals und schwert und
kann ich dich besser mit ich besser
essen kann ersehen kann ein bisschen
dunkel sollte nichts mehr passieren dass
hier oben zu super dann haben wir diesen
komischen und die sonne geht auch schon
wieder unterzahl mit dem schneemann
fertig werden nicht fällig ich wollte
hier noch sowas hin machen
so von wegen die warte ich mach das mal
auf die andere seite
weil sonst das symmetrisch mit der nah
sind das wäre nicht ganz so teuer sind
ist natürlich nie symmetrisch soweit es
mir gleich mache ich jetzt auch so wie
schön ich lieber dass diese abende hier
es ist dann immer so harmonisch 1 davon
im moment
stehe ich jetzt gerade nicht der
fashion-welt bekräftigte kitty kat 0
die monster ausmachen damit den export
fällt mir dazu auf nein ich lasse ihn
monster an
ich bin locker und entspannt
passt doch es war ja ich das jetzt sage
macht einen ganz anderen 2
2 wenn ich mir die ganze war dazu der
schneemann hat er sogar zwei fässchen
man kann erkennen dass es im schnee
mannes pasta und wispert ich mache hier
oben jetzt noch einen drauf weil sonst
sieht das nicht aus
das kann ich dir recht an den seiten
auch noch machen wenn ich meine nächsten
folge ein bisschen zeit habe mache ich
das dann noch ein bisschen schöner soll
ja nicht so hektisch werden den ganzen
folgen der ich mach das eine schließe
ich für euch die weihnachtszeit die
sollte nicht hektisch sein
außer beim geschenke einkaufen da ist
man nicht immer hektisch man erkennt das
ist ein schneemann ölwerte wie wir
stecken die noch sachen zu machen ihm
ohren
das sind ohren definitiv sind das ohr
und verdammt
so
schön
das ist doch mal ein wunderschöner
schneller also man kann auf jeden fall
erkennen
schneemann ist auch jetzt können wir
diese angucken aber du stehst man auch
über ihn
na gut also ich würd sagen auf jeden
fall die welt fühlt sich hier
mittlerweile werden immer mehr sachen
gebaut und wir sehen uns in der nächsten
folge schaffen wir eventuell 1000 1337
likes also 1337 schaffen wir das hier
die das kennen verstehen dass das wäre
echt mega geil und dann würde ich sagen
schreibt mir weiterhin themen und bau
vorschlägen die kommentare und wir sehen
jetzt denn mal